moviemaking isn't an exact science from
the biggest blockbusters to the cheapest
Z movies filmmakers all start out with a
desire to entertain but many times it
doesn't go as planned
the pieces just fail to come together
and we're left with a product that's
less than transcendent however there are
also times when those dysfunctional
pieces come together perfectly and a
film project transcends badness to
become something truly jaw-droppingly
spectacularly awful here are some of
those films Manos the hands of fate pal
Warren was a Texas fertilizer salesman
who happened to make the acquaintance of
Academy award-winning screenwriter
sterling silicon while working as an
extra on a TV show according to
Entertainment Weekly Warren proclaimed
to his friend that filmmaking was easy
and ended up betting that he could make
in star in a movie himself he wrote the
first treatment right there on a
cocktail napkin and one of the most
ill-conceived ideas in cinematic history
Manos the hands of fate was born the
film that resulted from the friendly bet
has so many problems that it would be
easier to catalog what didn't go wrong
shot for $19,000 the Z horror picture in
which a vacationing family stumbles
across a weird cult features long
dialogue free shots of people driving
reaction shots that don't appear to be
reactions to anything dead in subplots
shots that inexplicably linger on after
characters have stopped talking there's
no place like that around here
and overall some of the most poorly
delivered atrociously written dialog you
will ever hear that's 10 miles 10 miles
might as well be 10,000 mile it's
insanely shoddy production values have
become the stuff of legend especially
after the film's notorious roasting on
Mystery Science Theater 3000 you have to
want to help yourself
the film was lovingly restored by a fan
in 2011 so it's astonishing ineptitude
can be revisited by generations of
future filmmakers troll 2
the problems with troll 2 begin with the
fact that it is not in fact a sequel to
1986 as troll and the villains are
goblins
not trolls according to film school
rejects the film has become renowned for
its incredibly clunky heavy-handed
needlessly expository dialogue which was
the result of its screenplay being
written by a non-english speaker Italian
writer director Claudio Fragoso
I'm going to me despite appeals from his
amateur cast Fragoso insisted they
deliver each line exactly as written and
their enthusiastic overacting renders
nearly every line of dialogue control to
borderline excruciating the
cinematography and special effects are
appropriately amateurish the loopy plot
fails to ever follow through on its
occasional threat to make sense and it's
scenes of horror register is explicitly
comical
actor Michael Stevenson went on to
direct the 2009 documentary best worst
movie detailing his experience working
on troll 2 which contains the depressing
revelation that forgot for all these
years was under the impression that he'd
made an awesome movie I did a very good
movie if the others say last movie
then problem oh my gosh that's the worst
movie I've ever seen Mac and me the 1988
film Mac and me was an attempt about
five or six years too late
to cash in on the box-office breaking
success of Steven Spielberg's et the
extra-terrestrial but that's not all it
was it was also an attempt to further
cash in by stuffing the film to the brim
with arguably the most name-brand
products ever before seen on screen in
the movie a young wheelchair-bound boy
befriends a horrifyingly ugly
animatronic alien and the pair awkwardly
stumbled through a story that only
pauses long enough to prominently
feature corporate logos Mac and me is a
film that can't be bothered to present a
coherent plot yet has no trouble
grinding the proceedings to a halt for a
full-on music video style dance number
set entirely inside of a McDonald's
restaurant and the friendly aliens name
was surely no coincidence the dialogue
is overwhelmingly cheesy the alien looks
like it could have come from your
neighborhood Halloween store and the
plots lazy reworking of et is a name
even by the standards of cheaply
produced 80s kids movies Howard the Duck
it's tough to remember when Marvel
didn't utterly dominate the box office
but there was a time when Hollywood
simply had no idea how to handle their
properties for the strongest evidence of
Tinseltown's comic cluelessness look no
further than the very first big-screen
adaptation of a marvel property to call
1986 as Howard the Duck a starring
vehicle for a c-list character would be
generous but producer George Lucas
apparently felt he could do no wrong in
the mid 80s and he brought the full
staff of his company Industrial Light
and Magic and a 30 million dollar budget
to the production which would almost
instantly be pegged as one of the
biggest flops of its decade the film
isn't so much funny as it is deeply
weird throwing Howard who is
mysteriously transported to earth from
his native duck world together with
human love interest Beverly played by
Lea Thompson
it's a strange pairing in the comics
that's rendered downright disturbing in
live-action its tone-deaf attempts at
humor and creepy animatronics utterly
baffled audiences typical hairless ape
the film struggled to make back half its
budget domestically it showed the first
big chinks in Lucas's armor and tried
it's best for ruin a character who
wouldn't appear
on film again for nearly 30 years you
know this is beginning to seriously
undermine my self-esteem Birdemic shock
and terror if you gathered together a
group of random people with absolutely
no interest in film and forced them at
gunpoint to make a horror feature with
almost no money and fewer resources you
would end up with something that would
look a whole lot like 2008's Birdemic
shock and terror this complete ripoff of
Alfred Hitchcock's the birds tells the
simple story of a happy couple Wow
congratulations I think you look great
in those lingerie whose romance is
interrupted by an unexplained killer
bird infestation its overall aesthetic
shout on the cheap stiffly acted and
incompetently plotted despite the story
simplicity would have been more than
enough to earn the film its place among
the worst of the worst but the birds
themselves simply must be seen to be
believed
rendered with the absolute cheapest CGI
anyone has ever seen dropped clumsily
into the frame as our heroes swat at the
squawky menaces the repetitive grating
sound effects that accompany their
attacks just make the terror seem even
more ridiculous some observers have gone
so far as to wonder whether Birdemic was
actually intended to be funny according
to director James Wynn it wasn't
shocking and terrifying just like a
hundred million dollar picture Hollywood
style even this was like a hundred
million dollar picture well I think I'm
a distant you know movie 43 the
cringe-worthy movie 43 is the result of
an unearthly amount of determination on
the part of Peter Farrelly once better
known as the mastermind behind gross out
comedy classic there's something about
Mary
fairly envisioned a new breed of sketch
comedy a film that would play like a
series of Funny or Die skits but grosser
according to the Guardian Farrelly
adopted a strategy of waiting sometimes
for years to shoot segments based on his
star's availability and even moved the
production 3,000 miles to accommodate
Richard Gere through sheer patience
pestering and more than a little guilt
he managed to enlist major Hollywood
heavy hitters to completely embarrass
themselves in service of the most
horrifyingly unfunny so-called comedy
ever
Joost it's been ripped to shreds by
critics but it was famed critic Richard
Roeper who hit the nail on the head when
he said movie 43 is the Citizen Kane of
awful
[Music]